admiral shifting topics away from the
children's book to something that i
think is on the minds of a lot of adults
earlier in the show uh we played a clip
of an interview with general heighten
right number two general in the us
military who described a hypersonic
missile
that china has successfully tested right
sounds worrying to us yeah what do you
think when you hear that well i think
it's absolutely concerning and i think
david kind of posed the question was
this our sputnik moment uh you know
looking back on the soviets when they
launched sputnik and and a wake-up call
for us and and john highton i think
correctly answered it and said well i
don't know that it is a sputnik moment
but it's absolutely something we need to
be concerned about the chinese are
probably uh four to five years ahead of
us in this hypersonic technology
and it does present a potential first
strike capability for them uh so i know
that the the chairman and the the entire
joint chiefs are concerned about this
and rightfully so and it's great
question on david's part and
realistically what do we do about it
well we can we continue to advance our
technology we've got to continue to keep
an eye on china and their advancements
as well as whether or not this
technology begins to proliferate because
that's of equal concern do the russians
then begin to develop hypersonic
technology based on the chinese model i
mean these are the sort of things that
the department of defense will pay
particular attention to first use is the
same phrase that general heighten used
for us not in military parlance what
does that mean well you know during the
during the cold war era with the soviet
union we had kind of mutually assured
destruction this idea was nobody's going
to conduct a first use strike a first
strike because they understand that the
retaliation is worse than the strike
itself uh in this case the feeling is
with the first use if if and again i
caveat all of this i'm not overly
concerned that china is going to do this
but it does potentially put them in a
position to conduct a first strike
before we could launch a retaliatory
strike